in the context of the problem of
estimating the unknown bias of a coin we
encountered this distribution which is
known as a beta distribution it's a
probability density for a random
variable theta that takes values in the
interval from zero to one so this
formula is valid for Thetas in this
range and K here is a non-negative
integer now this coefficient here DN k
is a normalizing constant which is
needed so that this is a legitimate PDF
that it integrates to one and so in
particular D needs to be equal to the
integral of what we have in the
numerator this is the choice that makes
this whole expression integrate to one
and this integral is calculated and can
be found to be equal to this particular
expression how do we derive this
expression one way is to carry out the
long exercise in calculus we have this
integral here you might either expand it
and then integrate and collect terms or
you could try to demonstrate this
equality by applying integration by
parts but this is complicated is there
some simple way of arguing and deriving
this expression we will see that there
is a very simple probabilistic argument
for deriving this equality what we will
actually derive is this same equality
but in slightly different notation
instead of K we will use alpha instead
of n minus K we will use beta so here we
have alpha factorial times beta
factorial in the denominator we have the
sum of these two coefficients plus one
so this corresponds to alpha plus beta
plus one factorial this is what we want
to demonstrate what we will do will be
to consider the following setting we
start with alpha plus beta plus one that
many in
abandoned random variables that are
uniform on the unit interval and we will
consider the following event and its
probability this is the probability that
these random variables happen to be
ordered in some particular order
let us call this event a so this is the
probability of a now this probability is
not hard to calculate we have alpha plus
beta plus 1 random variables independent
identically distributed by symmetry any
particular way of ordering these random
variables is equally likely how many
ways are there to order alpha plus beta
plus 1 random variables
it's the factorial of the number of
items that we are trying to order we are
talking about the probability of a
particular permutation so this
probability is equal to 1 over the
number of permutations of alpha plus
beta plus 1 objects so this is one
expression for the probability of this
event a now we're going to calculate
this probability in a different way what
we will do is we are going to apply the
total probability theorem we're going to
condition on Z we are going to calculate
the conditional probability of a given
that Z takes a specific value and then
weigh those probabilities according to
the probability density of the random
variable Z so this is just the total
probability theorem applied to this
particular context and now to make
progress what we will need to do is to
find this conditional probability we fix
a constant little theta and we want the
probability that this event happens
what is this event it is the event that
all of the exes fall inside this
interval all the Y's fall inside this
interval and furthermore the exes are
sorted and the Y's are sorted so let us
write this out needs the probability
that all of the exes happen to be less
than theta all the Y's happen to be
bigger than theta and also not just that
but the X's are sorted and furthermore
the Y's are sorted as well
clearly if I give you the value of theta
so that Z is equal to theta for this
event to happen we must have all these
events here happened as well so now let
us try to calculate the probability of
this event we're going to use the
multiplication rule first take the
probability of this event and then the
conditional probability of that event
the X's and the Y's are independent so
we can take the probability of this
event and then multiply with the
probability of this event involving the
Y's how about the probability of this
event that all of the X's are less than
theta since the X's are independent this
is going to be equal to the probability
that X 1 is less than theta what is this
probability since X 1 is uniform on the
unit interval and this is theta the
probability of falling in this interval
is equal to theta times the probability
that X 2 is less than theta this
probability is again theta and so on we
have alpha many terms of that kind so
this probability that all of these
random verbs are less than theta is
equal to theta to the power of alpha
similarly about the Y's for any
particular y the probability that it
falls in this interval is equal to the
length of this interval which is 1 minus
theta this is the probability for each
one of the Y's
there's beta many Y's the Y's are
independent so the probability that all
of them fall in this interval is going
to be this number to the power of beta
so suppose that I told you that all the
X's are less than theta and then I asked
you given this information what is the
probability that the X's that you got
are arranged in
particular order now because of the
complete symmetry of the problem even if
I tell you that all the axes fall inside
this interval any order of the axis is
equally likely so the probability of
this particular order is going to be 1
over the number of possible orderings
how many ways are there that alpha items
can be ordered there are alpha factorial
possible orderings so the probability
that I obtain one particular ordering is
1 over alpha factorial and similarly if
I tell you that the Y's all fell in this
interval by symmetry the probability of
a particular order is going to be 1 over
the possible number of orders which is
beta factorial all right so we have this
conditional probability and now we can
go back to this formula and substitute
and what we obtain is the integral of
this expression theta to the alpha 1
minus theta beta 1 over alpha factorial
times 1 over beta factorial then we have
the density of Z but since G is uniform
the density is equal to 1 and then we
have a factor of D theta so what have we
achieved we calculated the probability
of the event a in two different ways and
we got two seemingly different answers
but these two answers have to agree
therefore this expression is equal to
that expression and now if you take this
factor 1 over alpha factorial times 1
over beta factorial and send it to the
other side of the equation what we
obtain is exactly the formula that we
wished to derive this example is an
instance of the following there are
certain formulas in
that are somewhat complicated to derive
and their derivations using for example
calculus are quite unintuitive
but once you interpret the various terms
that appear in such relation in a
probabilistic way you can sometimes find
very easy derivations and explanations
why such a formula has to be true